This is a quick recap. Let's compare the u from 10 minutes ago to the u of now.
The u who now knows about conservation of energy and gravitational potential energy.
Well, even 10 minutes ago you could have solved the problem with
let's say a ball dropping down in free fall.
Ten minutes ago you could have solve that and now could have solve that.
You know everything that you need to know to describe this motion. What about an incline plane?
Well 10 minutes ago, I think you could have solve this.
You know how to break forces down and solve for acceleration
and so now I see you could solve that as well.
When an incline plane is in a very realistic shape.
How often a nature do you see a hill that's perfectly flat at one single angle, not very often.
More often what you see in nature is weird strange shape like this one
and if you have a block of mass m on a hill like this,
could you calculate the speed of the block when it gets to the bottom.
I think 10 minutes ago, you may not be able to do that but now you can
and how are you going to do that?
Well as long as you know the height of the hill, you know that as the block slides down here
well, its potential energy would be described by this equation mgh.
As h goes down, potential energy will go down, but energy is conserved.
It can't be created. It can't be destroyed.
If potential energy is going down, kinetic energy must be going up
and in fact, at the very bottom of this hill once the block has gotten all the way down here
h is zero, so all of the potential energy is gone and converted into kinetic energy.
We can say that mathematically by saying that the potential energy the block had up here
is equal to the kinetic it has down here or mgh=1/2mv²
and what do you know the mass tells us.
The mass of the block doesn't matter. We can solve this equation for v to get this wonderful answer.
The velocity of this block at the bottom will be the √2gh. This answer is remarkable.
It doesn't depend on the mass and Galileo knew motion shouldn't really depend on mass.
It depends on this acceleration due to gravity as we expect it it's higher well the speed is higher.
It also depends on the height of the hill. Slide it down a higher hill and the velocity is greater.
This makes a lot of sense--now that your so much smarter than you were 10 minutes ago,
time to put this skills to use and solve some problems.